[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
الجيش الروسي يقول انه احبطه هجوما
اوكرانيا واسعا نطاق جنوب منطقه في خمسه
محاور
الوكاله الدوريه تجتمع في في عنا لبحث
ملفي
البحريه الامريكيه تنقذ سفينه تجاريه
تعرضت لمضايقات من الحرس الثوري الايراني
في مضيق هرمز
اطراف الازمه الليبيه توقع اليوم على
اتفاق بوزنيقه كخطوه الى الامام نحو
الانتخابات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اعلنت روسيا تصديها
لهجوم الاوكراني واسع النطاق وقالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه شنت
هجوما واسعا في خمسه قطاعات من الجبهه في
اتجاه جنوب منطقه
دبابات وفق ما ذكرته الدفاع الروسيه مضيفه
بان القوات الاوكرانيه لم تنجح في
استهدافها منطقه دوني ايسك وياتي ذلك في
الوقت الذي تقول فيه غياب انها تستعد
لهجوم مضاد واسع النطاق ضد القوات الروسيه
في صباح يوم الرابع من يونيو العدو هجوما
واسعا نطاق في خمسه قطاعات من الجبهه في
اتجاه جنوبسك من خلال ادخال الويه
ميكانيكيه في المعركه من الاحتياطات
الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه اجمالا شاركت ست
كتائب اليه وكتيبه دبابات للعدو وكان هدف
العدو هو اختراق دفاعاتنا لكن نتيجته نجاح
الاعمال القتاليه للم الشرقيه تم التصدي
للهجومي وبلغت خسائر الجيش الاوكراني اكثر
من 250 فردا وسته عشره دبابه وثلاث مركبات
قتال مشاه واحدى وعشرين عربه قتال مصفحه
في هذه الاثناء مشاهدينا اعلنا حاكم
مقاطعه
الناس فاشعلت النار في منشاه للطاقه في
المدينه ولم يسفن هجومه عن اصابات نتابع
جديده لمعادله فرض القوى بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وجهت سلطات موسكو في منطقه
شبكينو باقليمي بالجورود احد معاقل
الاقتتال الدائر بين الطرفين مناشدات
للسكان للتعاون مع السلطات ومغادره
منازلهم دعوات جديه تظهر حجم القلق الروسي
من اشتداد رقعه القصف الاوكراني على
الحدود منذ اسابيع
احس القرى وخصوصا منطقه شبكينو التي تعرضت
للقصف على الاستماع لموقف السلطات
والمغادره مؤقتا من منازلهم من اجل الحفاظ
على اهم شيء وهو حياتهم وحياه المقربين
منهم
هي حاله من الفوضى على الحدود بحسب مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه التي هددت بالتدخل لحمايه
بولغورود اذ لم تتصدق قوه موسكو هناك
لمحاولتك قلب موازين المعادله العسكريه
لصالحها والتقدم خطوه اضافيه امام موسكو
اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع في المستقبل
القريب ما يحدث في منطقه بلغرود لان ما
يحصل هناك هو استلاء على اراضي الاتحاد
الروسي والمنطقه لاجل هذا اشدد على اننا
سنذهب الى بالقرود لحمايه شعبنا الروسي
ا جديدا من خط المواجهه مع اوكرانيا فهي
واحده من المناطق الواقعه حاليا تحت نيران
كييف كونها تبعد 10 كيلومترات فقط عن
حدودها ماذا فعل الاف من السكان الى
النزوح هربا من ضربات الموت فهذه هي
الفتره الاكثر دمويه لمناطق اقليم بالقرود
منذ بدايه الحرب بحسب الخبراء
ومن دميه مشاهدينا معنا مراسل العربيه
رائد الاغبر اهلا بك رائد واخر التطورات
الميدانيه على ضوء هذا الهجوم الكبير الذي
سنته القوات الاوكرانيه في دونيسكو
مرحبا احمد مره اخرى لا بد من الاشاره الى
ان التطورات العسكريه مستمره هنا في
الازمه الاوكرانيه لا تتوقف لا ليلا ولا
نهارا ومحورين هامين هو محور وصول القوات
الاوكرانيه الى العمق الروسي الحديث عن
محاور مختلفه وهي محور بيلغراد محور كورسك
محور شبه جزيره القرم وايضا رستوف هذه
المناطق كلها متاخمه لاراضي اوكرانيه اذا
تحدثنا عن كورس فهي متاخمه لمقاطعه سومي
الاوكرانيه اذا تحدثنا عن رستو فهي متاخمه
لدانيتك واذا تحدثنا عن بيل جراده التي
شهدت بالامس حوالي 500 قذيفه وصاروخ سقطت
على المدينه فهي متاخمه لمقاطعه خاركب
الحديث خمسه كيلو مترات فقط تفصل القوات
الاوكرانيه عن بلده شبيكنا التي تتعرض
بشكل يومي لقصف اوكراني
نعود الى المحور الاهم وهو الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد الذي شنته القوات
الاوكرانيه في مناطق مختلفه محاور مختلفه
في مقاطعه الحديث عن محور اوغلادار من
الناحيه الجنوبيه الحديث عن محور مارن من
ناحيه الغربيه الحديث ايضا عن محور نظمي
خالفكا الحديث عن محاور عديد حتى باخمه
كانت الهجومات من الناحيه الجنوبيه
الغربيه تقول قوات الروسيه بانها صدت هذه
الهجومات ويعني حيدت مئات المقاتلين
وعشرات الاليات ما زالت المعارك مستمره
احمد
وتزداد ضراوه هذه المعارك بالامس كان حضور
قوي للسلاح الجو الروسي على طيله اليوم
الماضي هناك هجومات على مدينه افديفكا
التي تعتبر الاكثر سخونه يحاول الجيش
الروسي توسيع الطوق على مدينه افديفيكا
ويحاول اقتحام الحديث عن اكثر من 15
محاوله اقتحام ليله امس لكن لا تطور لا
تقدم للقوات الروسيه وسط مقاومه عنيفه
للجيش الاوكراني للدفاع عن هذه المدينه
ايضا محاور هامه
هل نتحدث في مارينكا عن حضور للقوات
الشيشانيه التي يقال انها بدات تشارك في
المعارك في هذه المنطقه مع الحديث عن دور
اكبر لهذه القوات في هذه المرحله الكبيره
من المواجهات بين او المرحله الهامه من
المواجهات الكبيره بين روسيا واوكرانيا
يعني مساله هامه جدا احمد وهي دور القوات
الخاصه الروسيه ان كانت الشيشانيه او
فاقنر او اي قوات مثل الفرقه الخامسه عشر
وهي الحديث عن افخاذ الحديث عن دور هذه
القوات المنفصله عن الجيش الروسي او
مرتبطه
ارتباطا فقط مع الجيش الروسي بالفعل وصلت
منذ ايام القوات الشيشانيه وبدات تستلم
مواقع في محور مدينه مارينكا للتفكير فقط
بان مارنكا فيها الجيش الروسي يسيطر على
ثلثي المدينه والمتبقي هو الثلث الاخير من
المدينه من الناحيه الغربيه وبدات القوات
الشيشانيه اعمالها بمزيد من الضربات ان
كان
براجمات الصواريخ او بالمدافع لان في هذه
الحربه في هذه المعارك احمد الاله
العسكريه الثقيله هي التي تلعب دورا كبيرا
في تغيير مسار المعركه اضافه الى المسيرات
ما تحققه من نجاحات حيث لا بد من الاشاره
وبعجاله بان هذه المنطقه
شهدت يوم امس تصريحات عن وصول الاف
المسيرات التي تتصنع في الداخل الروسي
وهناك مصانع هنا في
الاسلحه يعني الذخيره كما ان الجانب
الاوكراني
اعلن عن تصنيع اعداد كبيره عشرات الالاف
من المسيرات التي بات لها دور كبير
دعم الوقت في نشاط اللاحقه شكرا
في الدفاع الروسيه ان قوات اسطول المحيط
الهادئ بدات بتنفيذ مهام تدريبات عمليه في
مياه بحي اليابان وبحر اوحوتيسك وقالت
الوزاره في بيان من المناورات ستستمر حتى
العشرين من يونيو وفي مياه بحي اليابان
بمشاركه اكثر من 60 سفينه حربيه روسيه
وسفينه الدعم ونحو 35 طائره بحريه واكثر
من احد عشر الف جندي من القوات البحريه
بمبادره من اعضاء من البرلمان الليتواني
سيعقد الاسبوع الجاري بل في الاسبوع
الجاري مؤتمر يناقش بالمؤتمر ان يناقش
مستقبل روسيا ومعارضتها في البرلمان
الاوروبي في بروكسل وذلك بحسب صحيفه
بوليتيكو التي اشارت الى ان المؤتمر سيجري
بل سيجرى بمشاركه نحو
الحرب فضلا عن معارضين وصحافيين وسياسيين
ومثقفين حيث ستتم مناقشه مواضيع منها
مستقبل روسيا والاستراتيجيه المستقبليه
للمعارضه الروسيه الصحيفه مشاهدينا ذكرت
ايضا انه استعدادا لهذا المؤتمر اجتمعت
نحو 70 جماعه المناهضه للحرب في اوكرانيا
والمعارضه الروسيه في برلين في ابريل
الماضي الاتفاق على اعلان مشترك وقعه حتى
الان 30 الف روسي
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي لدى لقائه نظيره
الهندي في نيودله قال ان تطوير الشراكات
الدفاعيه في المنطقه بات امرا مهما للحفاظ
على السلام والامن الاقليميين وضمانهما
ومواجهه النفور الصيني
نحن متحدون وسنواجه كل المحاولات الهادفه
لتقويض النظام الحالي والذي تحكمه قواعد
ساهمت خلال العقود الماضيه في احلال
السلام وتحقيق الازدهار في هذه المنطقه
انني اتطلع الى مناقشه التقدم الذي
احرزناه والارضيه الجديده التي نسعى
لكسبها وتحقيقها في مجال مشاركه المعلومات
والامن البحري والتعاون الدفاعي والصناعي
والتكنولوجي ستعزز الاستثمارات التي نقوم
بها في دمج قطاعات الدفاع امننا المشتركه
على المدى الطويل
عن عقد نحو 20 من اجهزه المخابرات الكبرى
في العالم اجتماعا وذلك على هامش اجتماعات
حوار شنغه الامني المقام في سنغافوره
اجتماع سري لقاده اجهزه المخابرات في
سنغافوره وذلك على هامش اجتماعات حوار
الامني مصادر رويترز اكدت ان الاجتماع
يعقد سرا منذ عده سنوات فعلى الرغم من
الرفض الصيني لعقد لقاء عسكري مع امريكا
الا ان الاجتماع نجح في ضم القوتين
العالميتين حيث اكدت المصادر حضور مديره
المخابرات الامريكيه افريل هاينز فيما لم
يعرف الممثل الصيني في الاجتماع اما
الممثل الروسي فكان الغائب الحاضر عن
الاجتماع
حيث نوقشت الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في
الاجتماع وفقا للمصادر المصادر قالت ان
الاجتماع لم يكن مخابراتيا بحثا بل كان
وسيله لتعزيز فهم النوايا خصوصا مع تزايد
التوترات في العالم
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل في
معركه ضد الاعلام الانبار تتراقب موثور
الامير هاري لادلاء بشهادته امام محكمه
بريطانيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد ونبدا بهذه
الصور المباشره من امام المحكمه العليا
البريطانيه حيث من المتوقع ان يدلي اليوم
الامير هاري بافادته امام هذه المحكمه
المحكمه العليا في بريطانيا في قضيه ضد
مجموعه ميرور للنشر وذلك على خلفيه مزاعم
حول استخدام المجموعه لمحققين واختراقها
ايضا لهاتفه للحصول على معلومات تم
استخدامها في صناعه الاخبار لاحقا يكون
بذلك الامير هاري اول فرد رفيع المستوى من
الاسره المالكه يقدم ادله امام محكمه منذ
عام
ويعتذر لكم مشاهدينا في وقت تصف فيه وسائل
الاعلام البريطانيه هذه المحاكمه بقضيه
العصر افاده امير حارم مشاهدينا تعتبر
ايضا حاسمه في معركه هذه ضد الصحافه التي
يلومها
في وفاته والدته وكذلك في تعقيد وتخريب
علاقته بعائلته منذ زواجه بميجا ماركل عام
مشاهدينا الان ننتقل الى الهند لمتابعه
هذه الكلمه لوزير الدفاع الامريكيه
وصلت بشجاعه بتنويع معداتها على مدى العقد
الماضي ونحن نتطلع لاستمرار اعمالنا معهم
لزياده قدراتنا معا
السؤال التالي
شكرا لكم
وصف شراكه الامريكيه الهنديه على انها
متتاليه على مدى القرن 21 هل توافق مع ذلك
التقييم وما هي العقبات الاساسيه
الوفاء
هذه الشراكه وقدره روسيا لتوصيل لايصال
اسلحه هل تستفيد
الولايات المتحده من فرصتها لايصاله
سلاحها الى الهند بدلا من روسيا
الولايات المتحده والهند لهما علاقه
متواصله نعم بالتاكيد هذه
نتحدث عن اكبر ديمقراطيه الديمقراطيات
العالم نعمل
بقدرات كبيره في هذه المنطقه ومره ثانيه
هذه الدول المتشابهه في العقليه تعمل
لتحقيق نتائج دائمه وهي امور عملنا معها
على مدى سنوات طويله والناس جعل المنطقه
امنه
تدفق الافكار بشكل ايجابي فيها هذه مساله
مهمه جدا والعلاقه مهمه بالنسبه لنا
ماذا عن العقبات المتعلقه بالسلاح الروسي
العقبات
امام العلاقه الدفاعيه
نحن نركز على كل المزايا
التي يمكن ان نحققها ومره ثانيه اعيد هنا
ربما
نحدد الاف العقبات لكن هناك فرص كبيره جدا
واعتقد ان نركز على ما يمكن
النجاح به مع شركائنا وايجاد الصالح العام
لهذه المنطقه
ولصالحي
قواعدنا الصناعيه وجيشينا
السؤال الاخير شكرا لك الوزير نعلم ان
الولايات المتحده تدرس استخدام الهام بيس
واسئله المختلف الامريكي هل تعرفون ان
كانت هذه مركبات امريكيه وان كانت قد وصلت
بمساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا وهل تتابعون
سلاح
والمركبات العسكريه التي يمكن ان تصل الى
اوكرانيا
هل هذه الامور تحدث
وتبقى ضمن حدود محدده قلت مرارا اننا نركز
على
لشركائنا في اوكرانيا
اننا
نستخدم
سلاحنا
لعمليات
الهجوميه في اوكرانيا هذا امر لا نشجع
عليه بالنسبه
لقدراتنا لمتابعه
ومراقبه سلاحنا نحن نواصل
التقدم ولكن هناك
حدود وهي عدد الافراد الموجودين لنا في
اوكرانيا لكن بقول هذا اؤكد ان
الاوكرانيين ساعدونا في الوصول الى هذه
المناطق التي يجب ان نصل اليها وندرس كل
الامور على الارض وسنواصل
موقفنا وتقديم المعدات
وهي لاستخدام
لادفاع عن السياده على ارضهم وما زلنا
نستخدم القدرات الرقابيه
وقد قطعنا طرق عديده ولن تكون الامر امور
مثاليه الى عندما يكون لدينا اعداد كبيره
على الارض بالنسبه للوضع بالقرات هل لديك
اي تحديث عن هذا الامر كلا ليس لدينا شيء
شكرا
معكم في متابعه لهذا المؤتمر الصحفي من
نيودلهي لوزير الدفاع الامريكي وقال قبل
قليل كما تبعنا سنواصل تقديم المساعدات
والمعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا واضاف ايضا
وزير الدفاع
اننا سنواصل بل اكدنا لاوكرانيا عدم
استخدام الاسلحه الامريكيه في هجمات ضد او
خارج الحدود وندعم حريه الملاح والتجاره
في منطقه المحيطين نواصل المشاهدين هذه
النشره اذا فقد اتهم رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بالتقصير في مراقبه انشطه ايران النوويه
وذلك خلال اجتماع لمجلس الوزراء الامني
المصغر في غرفه قياده تحت الارض لمحاكاه
اتخاذ القرار خلال حرب محتمل مع ايران
وقيل اجتماع ايضا مشاهدينا اكاديمياهو
التزام بلاده بالعمل ضد ما اسماه بمساعي
ايران النوويه واكد ان وكاله الطاقه
الذريه تخاطر بان تصبح هيئه مسيسه
وبالتالي تفقد اهميتها على حد وصفه
اصبحت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
منظمه سياسيه فلن تكون هناك اهميه لنشاطها
في ايران ولا يكون هناك معنى لتقارير التي
تنشرها عن انشطه ايران النوويه على اي حال
فان اسرائيل تحت قياده حكومتنا لم تقف
مكتوفه الايدي
فيينا ملفات نوويه عده سيبحثها الاجتماع
ربع السنوي لمجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه المقارنه انعقاده اليوم
فبحسب بيان للوكاله فانه سيتم مناقشته
ملفات في مقدمتها عمليات التحقق والرصد في
ايران في ضوء اتفاق طيران الاخير مع
الوكاله المتعلق باستخدام الكاميرات
لمراقبه المواقع النوويه فضلا عن مناقشه
مدى التزام طهران باتفاقيه الضمانات
الخاصه بمعاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه وياتي هذا الاجتماع مشاهدينا ايضا
عقب او بعد تقريرين سريرين للوكاله جاء في
احدهما ان ايران تجاوزت السقف المسموح به
لها بتخزين يورانيوم المخصب باكثر من 23
مره كما لفت البيان الى ان مجلس محافظي
الوكاله سينظر ايضا في مساله تطبيق
الضمانات في كوريا الشماليه اضافه الى
تنفيذ اتفاقيات ضمانات معاهده عدم انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه في سوريا
مشاهدينا من فيينا معنا ممارسه العربيه
رغده بهنام اهلا بك راغده وما الذي سيناقش
يناقشه اجتماعه مجلس محافظ الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بشان ايران اليوم
اهلا بك يعني نعلم بانه في الاجتماع
الماضي في مارس كان هناك نقطتين اساسيتين
رفعهما امين عام الوكاله رفايا القرصي
تحدث بانه كان هناك رصد للمفتشين الدوليين
لاثار يورانيوم مخصبه بشكل بدرجه مرتفعه
جدا وصلت الى اكثر من 83% وهذه نسبه خطيره
جدا هذه واحده من النقاط التي سيناقشها
ولكن الملفت بانه جراسي في تقريره قبل
ايام الذي رفعه امام مجلس المحافظين قال
بانه الان
حصلت الوكاله على رد من ايران وبانه هذا
الرد هو شاف حتى الان وبانه يبدو بانه
الوكاله اقتنعت بانه رد ايران بان هذا
التخصيب بهذه الدرجه المرتفعه كان بشكل
يعني عرضي وليس يعني بشكل دائم هذه نقطه
نقطه ثانيه ايضا يعني تتعلق بمساله
التحقيق الذي تجريه الوكاله منذ عام 2018
في ثلاثه مواقع سريه لم تكشف عنها ايران
يعتقد بانه كان فيها النشاطات نوويه سريه
الان ابلغ دروس مجلس المحافظين ايضا في
تقرير الاسبوع الماضي يعني قبل ايام بانه
حصل على رد شافا حول واحد من هذه المواقع
الثلاث ما يعني بانه واحده من هذه يعني
الاسئله التي ترفعها الوكاله لايران منذ
ثلاث سنوات من دون ردود سيتم اغلاقه ولكن
هذه النقطه بحد ذاتها تتسبب في اسئله
وانتقادات لدى البعض كما سمعنا بانه رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي مثلا يقول بانه هذا
يعرض مصداقيه الوكاله للتهديد الان الرفي
البروسلي سيتحدث الصحفيين بعد قليل سيعقد
مؤتمر صحفي وبالطبع يرد على كل هذه
الاسئله لانه لم نسمع بعد حتى الان ما هو
رد جرس حول هذه النقطه تحديدا حول
الاتهامات بانه الوكاله ربما فقدت
مصداقيتها او تفقد مصداقيتها في حال يعني
وافقت على اغلاق هذه النقاط يعني التي
تعهدت بان لا تقفلها في الموقع الا لغايه
الحصول على يعني اسئله او اجوبه شافيه من
ايران تفضل
اجواء ربما توصف بالايجابيه ولو كان نسبيا
بين الوكاله الدوريه التقديريه وايران
ايضا
سؤالي هو حول ان وفق هذه المعطيات يعني هل
تشير هذه المعطيات الى ان الاوضاع ماضيه
بين الطرفين نحو التصعيد ام التهدئه
باختصار رغده
بالفعل الان قبل لحظات كنت اتحدث مع
دبلوماسي اوروبي وهو في طريقه للمشاركه
يعني لدخول هذه الاجتماعات كان يقول لي
بانه التقدم المحرز في التعاون بين
الوكاله وبين ايران ليس كبيرا هناك شيء من
التقدم ولكن هذا ليس التقدم الذين اود ان
نراه قال ايضا بانه برنامج ايران النووي
وحسب تقرير بروسي ما زال يتقدم بشكل سريع
جدا وهذا امر مثير جدا للقلق بالنسبه
الينا ولكن بالفعل كما فهمت بانه هذا
الاسبوع التركيز لن يكون على ايران بمعنى
تركيز التصعيد لن يكون على ايران يعني
الكلام على طرح مشروع قرار جديد هذا
الاسبوع لادانه ايران مستبعد جدا هذه
المره لانه يعني على الارجح الاشارات التي
تحدث عنها الاشارات الايجابيه التي تحدث
عنها
ربما يعني تقنع الان الدول الغربيه
بالتريث واعطائره وقت اضافي
تحيه راغبه
قالت البحريه الامريكيه ان بحارتها وعناصر
من البحريه البريطانيه ساعدوا سفينه في
مضيق هرمز بعد تعرضها لمضايقات من زوارق
هجوميه سريعه تابعه لحرس الثوري الايراني
واوضحت البحريه الامريكيه في بيان ان
ثلاثه زوارق سريعه على متنها جنود مسلحون
اقتربت بشده من السفينه التجاريه المجهوله
امس الاحد
عبر المدمر يو اس اس
وفرقاطه البحريه البريطانيه
على هذا الحادث
وبعد يومين من الحدث الحدودي مشاهدينا بين
مصر واسرائيل ظهرت اول صوره للجنديه
المصري للعمليه التي اسفرت عن مقتله ومقتل
ثلاثه جنود اسرائيلي اسرائيليين واصابه
اثنين اخرين كما تبين ان جنديا يدعى محمد
صلاح ابراهيم ويبلغ من العمر 23 عاما بحسب
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وكان ايضا هذا
الجني مشاهدينا يخدم عسكريا في منطقه
سيناء فيما كشف مغردون ان اصدقائه كانوا
يلقبونه بالرسام لشغفه بالرسم وكان محبوبا
بين معارفه مؤكدين ان خدمته العسكريه كانت
ستنتهي قريبا
كشف عضو لجنه البرلمان الليبيه عز الدين
قويرب كشف العربي عن نيه البرلمان الليبي
قوانين ايجار الانتخابات بعد الاعلان عنها
غدا بحضور رئيسي مجلسي النواب والدوله
مضيفا خلال حديثه للعربي ايضا عن وصول
البرلمان الى تفاهم النهائي بشان قوانين
الانتخابات الليبيه وانا المترشحين
الانتخابات الرئاسيه سيخوضون جولتي تصويت
اجباريا هذا وذكرت ايضا بل ذكر عضو اللجنه
عن البرلمان ان العسكريين المترشحين
الانتخابات سيكونون مستقلين بل مستقلين
حكما عند تقديم اوراق الترشح وانه لن يتم
السماح بترشح من صدر بحقه حكم نهائي او
جنايه
مشاهدينا من القاهره معنا الباحث السياسي
الليبي محمد الاسمر اهلا بك سيدي اسمر
معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه اتفاق
بوزنيقه الذي يتوقع ان يتم توقيعه اليوم
هل هو
خطوه بالفعل نحو هذه الانتخابات ام قفزه
نحو الظلام كما يحاول البعض ان يصور ذلك
اهلا وسهلا مرحبا حياكم الله هو تعبير
دقيق هو في حده الاقصى خطوه لان هذه
العمليه الانتخابيه متركبه بشكل معقد من
العديد من الاجراءات والتعقيدات ولكن
الباب الاول ان العمليه السياسيه بقت
راكده ومتجمده في اقرار القاعده الدستوريه
لانتاج القوانين الانتخابيه لقاءات عديده
بين الطرفين لم يتم التوافق بها على
النقاط الخلافيه المهمه فيما يتعلق
بالمترشحين لمنصب الرئاسه لا ننسى ان
اللجنتي المشكلتين من مجلس نواب والدوله
كانت انطلاقها منذ ديسمبر 2015 فقس الماده
15 حول منصب السياديه الى يومنا هذا لم
يتم الاتفاق بشانها باي شكل من الاشكال
اذا ما تم فعل التوافق والتوقيع هنا
انهينا مرحله الصياغه الخاصه بالقاعده
السوريه ولكن فيما بعدها تحويل ذلك الى
قانون واحالته المفوضيه الانتخابات
نعم ان هذا الاتفاق ادام انجز ونفذ
سيطرح وجها اخر لاشكال الليبي بان المشكله
لم هي لا تتمثل فقط في عدم انتاج القاعده
الدستوريه وانتاج قوانين ناظم العمل
الانتخابيه بقانونين الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه بل ان هناك مشاكل اكبر كانت
تختفي خلفها مشكله انتاج القاعده
الدستوريه نعم شكرا لك من القاهره كنت
معنا الباحثه النبي محمد الاسمر
العمليه الامنيه التي اطلقتها حكومه
الدببه في غرب ليبيا لمحاربه الخارجين عن
القانون وفق قولها باستخدام الطيران
المسير لاقت استهجان بعض الاطراف بحجه ان
المقصود منها ازاحه من يعارضه سياسيا منير
الاشهب والتفاصيل
ضربات جويه متتاليه باستخدام طيران مسير
على مواقع غرب ليبيا اعلنت حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه انتهاء مرحلتها الاولى والبدء في
المرحله الثانيه منها والتي تستهدف اوكار
الجريمه بحسب رئيس الحكومه
مواقع خطوط التهريب وخطوط التهريب البشره
وتهريب البنزينه او دخول
الكوكايين والهيروين والمخدرات بجميع
انواعها خصومه يتهمونه باستغلال المطالب
الشعبيه لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه في ظل
التقارب بين مجلسين النواب والدوله حكومه
استغل
ت هذه الحدث حتى الاحداث النبيله تحاول
تحولها
[موسيقى]
استغلها بشكل يخدم مصالحها
المخدرات
نائب بيت نائب في مجلس النواب تصفيه
حسابات سياسيه هذا هو مدخله منطقه ابو صره
في مدينه الزاويه والتي كان لها نصيب
الاسد من القصف الجوي بالطيران المسير
الذي تديره حكومه الوحده الوطنيه بطرابلس
والتي تقول انها قصفت مواقعا لتهريب البشر
والوقود فيما يقول معارضها ان المواقع
التي استهدفت هي لمعارضيه بيبه فقط
ابو مجلس النواب عن المنطقه علي ابو زريبه
اكد في اكثر من مناسبه ان القصف استهدفه
بشكل شخصي بعد استضافته الاجتماع بين
اعضاء مجلسي النواب والدوله لمناقشه ملف
توحيد الحكومه تفاجا بضرب الطيارات مسيره
على منزل الخاص
متواجد في عائلتي وابنائي يتحدث مواطنون
من داخل ابو صره على انهم يؤيدون محاربه
الجريمه في المنطقه الغربيه بالكامل
ولكنهم مثل قولهم يستغربون من استهداف
منطقتهم التي شهدت في فتره الماضيه بناء
بعض المرافق الحيويه التي كانت تفتقر لها
على حد قولهم نحن سكان مصر نستنكر هذا
العمل لان فعلا لا يوجد ما يستدعي ضربات
جويه للاماكن الامن مستغرب في الموضوع
القصف اللي حصل لنا وترعيب الاطفال
وتراعيب النساء وترعب الشيوخ يعني مش
معقول يجي طائره تقصفنا في بصره
تاتي وتقصف منطقه سكانها امنون
في على سبه انك تعرف الارهاب فهذا والله
الى الظلم في المنطقه اعربوا عن خشيتهم من
ارسال حكومه الوحده قوه بريه ما يعني وفق
قولهم عوده الاقتتال في المنطقه الغربيه
وسط تدخلات سياسيه وقبليه منير الاشهب
ليبيا العربيه
من المتوقع ان يدلي الامير هاري اليوم
افادته امام المحكمه العليا في بريطانيا
في قضيه ضد مجموعه ميرور للنشر على خلفيه
مزاعم حول استخدام المجموعه لمحققين
واختراقها لهاتفه للحصول على معلومات تم
استخدامها لاحقا في صناعه الاخبار ليكون
بذلك اول فرد رفيع المستوى بالاسره
المالكه يقدم ادله امام محكمه منذ عام
1891 في وقت تصف فيه وسائل الاعلام
البريطانيه هذه المحاكمه بقضيه العصر
وتعتبر افاده امير هاري حاسمه في معركه ضد
الصحافه التي يلومها في وفاه والدته وفي
تخريب علاقته بعائلته منذ زواجه بميكن
مايكل عام 2018
المحكمه العليا في بريطانيا حيث تترقب
الانظار ستشهد مثول الامير هاري للادلاء
بشهادته في قضيه ضد مجموعه ميرور جروب
نيوز بيبرز وهي المؤسسه التي تصدر صحفا
دينمير
وصندي بيبل
شهاده هاري ستكون الاولى لشخصيه بارزه من
العائله الملكيه منذ اكثر من 130 عاما
بماذا سيللي الامير هاري للمحكمه العليا
اتهام مجموعه ميرور
باستخدام محققين واختراق هاتفه الشخصي
محاوله الحصول على معلومات
واستخدامها في صناعه الاخبار
مقربون من الامير الشاب قالوا انه سيكون
حاسما في معركته ضد المجموعه الاعلاميه
خاصه وان هاري يلوم الاعلام بوفاه والدته
وتدمير علاقته مع العائله الملكيه
جلسه الاستماع للامير هاري وحسب فريق
الادع هي واحده من ثلاث قضايا يخوضها ضد
الصحافه البريطانيه بينها
لكن كيف ستكون الاسئله داخل المحكمه
العليا من المحتمل ان يواجه هاري استجوابا
تفصيليا حول المعلومات الشخصيه التي يدعي
انه تم الحصول عليها بشكل غير قانوني
بالاضافه الى اسئله طويله وربما مرهقه حول
افراد العائله الملكيه وعن والدته الراحله
امكانيه استخدام القضاء لمذكرات هاري ضده
خاصه فيما يتعلق برواياته عن طاعات
المخدرات وعلاقته المتوتره مع العائله
الملكيه لكن الامير هاري وحسب محاميين يصر
على رغبته في تغيير المشهد الاعلامي في
المملكه المتحده ولن يتنازل عن معركته ضد
مجموعه ميرور غروب نيوز بيبرز التي
يقاضيها ايضا اكثر من مئه شخص حول ارتكاب
اعمال غير قانونيه نفتها الاخيره وانكر
كبار مسؤوليها معرفه اي شيء حول اختراق
الهواتف
من لندن مشاهدينا معنا مراسل عربيه مصطفى
زارو اهلا بك مصطفى ومتى ستبدا جلسات هذه
المحكمه في الانعقاد وما الذي نتوقعه خلال
الساعات المقبله
حقيقه في اقل من ساعه من الان ستبدا جلسه
الاستماع في المحكمه خلفي حيث يتابعها
عشرات
الفرق المصورين
لعده قنوات محليه ودوليه يفترض ان يشارك
الامير هاري في هذه الجلسه ما بين اليوم
ويوم الاربعاء هو مجدول ان يقدم افادته
وشهاداته
داخل المحكمه غدا ولكن نتوقع ايضا ان يكون
حاضرا اليوم في هذه الجلسه دون تقديم اي
افادات وبالتالي الكاميرات يعني مرصوده
هنا في المدخل الرئيسي للمحكمه وايضا هناك
كاميرات اخرى في المدخل الخلفي لهذه
المحكمه الكل يتابع هذه القضيه التي تم
رفعها من قبل الامير ها عام 2019 والان
بعد كل هذه السنوات وجمع الادله كان هناك
ما يقارب بحسب فريق فريق محاماه الامير
هاري ان هناك ما يقارب من 148 مقالا
استخدمت فيه يعني امور شخصيه خاصه به حصل
عليها صحفيون او محققون يعملون لصحيفه
المرر بطرق غير الشرعيه للكشف عنها ونشرها
في الصحف ولكن سيتم اعتماد فقط
33 مقالا بحسب الفريق تم نشر هذه المقالات
ما بين سته وتسعين 2011 والكل يترقب ما
اذا كان سيسمح للامير هذه مواصله هذه
المحاكمه والخروج بنتيجه ايجابيه لان
حقيقه لا احد يعرف او يتكهن كيف ستكون هذه
النتيجه بعد سته اسابيع تقريبا من
المرافعات طيب مصطفى يعني نتحدث عن ان
الامير هاري هو اول فرم رعايه الملكه ربما
افادتها او شهادته امام المحكمه او يقدم
ادله امام المحكمه منذ 130 عاما
هل صدر اي موقف من العائله المالكه عن
متابعتها لهذه التطورات عن موقف ايضا من
هذه الخطوه التي اتخذها الامير هاري
ما ما اقدم عليه الامير هري هو خارج عن
التقليد للاسره الملكيه البريطانيه يعني
حاليا الملك تشارلز خارج المملكه المتحده
وهو في اجازه يعني في رومانيا في
بالتحديد حيث يملك يعني بيت هناك لربما
سيقضي بعض الايام هناك ولكن ايضا لا نعرف
اذا ما كنا اي ترتيبات للقاء ممكن احد
افراد الاسره الملكه ولكن بالطبع
التكتم الواضح معروف لدى الاسره المالكه
ولكن الامير هاني مختلف تماما ويريد ان ان
ان تكون هذه المحاكمه ان نكسب منها على
الاقل اعاده يعني شخصيته او اعاده ما كان
ينشر في سابقا في الصحف البريطانيه وخاصه
الامور الدقيقه والش يقول الامير هاري
بانه تم الحصول على بطرق غير الشرعيه ولكن
يعني صحيفه يعني تقول بان هذه المعلومات
تم الحصول عليها من اصدقاء من اولئك
المقربين من الامير هل وحتى اولئك الذين
عملوا في الجيش مع الامير هاري خلال
قضاء عندما عندما كان يعني عنصرا في الجيش
البريطاني كمساعد الطيار طيب وسيكون نحن
معك في متابعه دائمه لتطورات هذه القضيه
مستفزه وشكلك مصطفى ومشاهدينا نبقى معكم
في متابعه هذه الصور من العاصمه بريطانيه
لندن من امام المحكمه العليا حيث من
المتوقع كما اشرنا قبل قليل ان يدلي
الامير هاري اليوم بافادته امام هذه
المحكمه في قضيه
مرفوعه ضد مجموعه للنشر على خلفيه مزاعم
حول استخدام هذه المجموعه
لمحققين وايضا لاختراقها هاتفه لحصوله على
معلومات خاصه به تم استخدام ها لاحقا في
صناعه الاخبار
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
مخاوف بامكانيه استخدام روبوتات الدردشه
في تجديد ارهابي
الجيش الروسي يقول انه احبطه هجوما اخريا
واسعا نطاق جنوب منطقه في خمسه محاور
الوكاله الدوليه تجتمع في فيينا لبحث ملفي
ايران النووي يتهمها
البحريه الامريكيه تنقذ سفينه تجاريه
تعرضت لمضايقات من الحرس الثوري الايراني
في مضيق هرمز
اطراف الازمه الليبيه توقع اليوم على
اتفاق بوزنيقه كخطوه الى الامام نحو
الانتخابات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد حذر خبراء في
الجامعات الارهابيه من امكانيه استخدام
روبوتات الدردشه في تجنيد ارهابيهم وبحسب
صحيفه الجارديا فان الخبراء اعربوا عن
قلقهم ان برامج الدردشه الالكترونيه التي
تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان تكون اداه
لاقناع الافراد الضعفاء او المختلفين في
الاراء والافكار بتنفيذ هجمات ارهابيه
الجارديا مشاهدينا اضافه ايضا في تقريرها
ان خبراء في مراقبه الارهاب اكدوا ان
تهديد الامن القومي بواسطه الذكاء
الاصطناعي اصبح اكثر وضوحا من اي وقت مضى
وان مبتكر التكنولوجيا بحاجه الى وضعنا
وايد ارهابيين في الاعتبار عند تصميمها
في القاهره بحث اتحاد الاثريين العرب ما
تتعرضوا له بعض المناطق التراثيه من
ارتداءات تهدد ما بها من تراث واطلق
المجتمعون والمشاركون في ندوه تحت عنوان
تراث القاهره المعماري وحتميه الحفاظ اطلق
نداءه لوقف اي اعمال هدم في المواقع
التراثيه داخل نطاق القاهره التاريخيه
الحياه ضروري من اعاده النظر في كيفيه
الموائمه بين المشروعات الجديده وبين
الاثار والممتلكات المصريه الوطنيه الهامه
التي لا يجب المساس بها يعني احنا لا
نطالب بوقف الاعمار والتعمير والمد الطرق
ولكن يجب ان يكون مدروس في اطار الحفاظ
على الثقافه المصريه
للسياح لان في مناطق فيها جميله جدا
بالعكس كان ممكن ترميه وكان يكون يضيف الى
اقتصاديا الى
للدوله
نرفض في
كاسريين نرفض هذه الكلمه لانها كلمه غير
غير مصرفه في اي فيرب او في اي جمله من
الجمل اللي ممكن تتعرب كلمه تطوير بالنسبه
للاثار يعني اهانه الاثر نحن نتعامل مع
كلمه صيانه الاثار نتعامل مع ترميم الاثار
نتعامل مع اعاده تاهيل الاثار
قال وزير الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه قال انه كانت هناك حاجه لاتخاذ
اجراء اضافي في ظل الظروف الراهنه مشيرا
الى انه حصل توافق على تمديد تخفيضات
الانتاج النفطي الى نهايه 2004 وعشرين
اعتقد انه كل الاجراءات من الاخيره حتى في
شهر ابريل تخفيض اللي سوت الدول المشاركه
معنا
لمنفرده سويتك كقرار منفرد لكل دوله هو
قرار تحوطي
واعتقد انه
في ظل الظروف الراهنه كان في حاجه لاتخاذ
اجراء اضافي لكن تقديرنا هو انه في كان
بتكون صعوبات على دول لم نتواصل مع احد
لكن لانه حتى الدول قادره على التخفيض كان
لهم تخفيض في ابريل
لسه بادي نتائج المفروض نشوف تقييم
النتائجها في في منتصف يونيو
واضاف وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ان افضل وسيله لمعالجه
الامور هو الاعتماد على منظور واضح مشيرا
الى ان جهات مستقله ستعمل مع دول اوبك بلس
بشان تقييم انتاجها في 2024
تعبنا من تعطي دول الحصص ما قادره تنتجها
تعبنا من
ادعاءات انه هذه دوله تقدر انها تنشج كذا
وتقدر تنشف فقلنا افضل وسيله
لمعالجه الامور هذه اللي يسمونه
بالانجليزي
انه عندك منظور او مدى واضح
تتصرف هذا المدى يتعزز عندما تكون الياتك
منضبطه باجراءات تمكن من تعزيز الموثوقيه
فيها
مشاهدي الشرطه في افغانستان نقل 60 تلميذه
الى المستشفى بعد تعرضهن للتسمم في
مدرستهن في شمال البلاد ووقعت حاله التسمم
باقليم ساريبول حيث اكد مسؤولون في الشرطه
ان مجهولنا سمم الفصول ولكنه لم يفضي عن
الماده المستخدمه او من يشتبه في
مسؤوليتهم عن الواقعه كما لم يعلن اعتقال
اي شخص على خلفيه الحادث
تطور طبي مبشر في مساعي الحد من مرض
السكري وعلاجه بعد ان تمكن علماء من
اختراق الخلايا البشريه التي تنتج
الانسولين وقد دراسه حديثه نشرتها مجله
البيولوجي الباحثون ياملون في ان يساعد
البحث في دفع الجسم الى انتاج الانسولين
بشكل طبيعي مره اخرى لمرضى السكري الذي
يعتبر واحدا من اسرع الامراض المزمنه
انتشارا على مستوى العالم وفقا لدراسه
اجريت عام 2022
[موسيقى]
وقبل ختام هذه الساعه الاخباريا نذكر
بعبرز العناوين
الجيش الروسي يقول انه احبطه هجوما
اوكرانيا واسعا نطاق جنوب منطقه
الدوليه تجتمع في فيينا لبحث ملف ايران
النووي لطيران
البحريه الامريكيه تنقذ سفينه تجاريه
تعرضت لمضايقات من الحرس الثوري الايراني
في مضيق هرمز
اطراف الازمه الليبيه توقع اليوم على
اتفاق بوزنيكا كخطوه الى الامام نحو
الانتخابات
نهايتها في امان الله
[موسيقى]
القصه الانسانيه والوثائقيه والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات